Hello
bitches.
I would love to play you.
The dinosaurs are not real video.
Do it.
God.
See if he flagged JV.
We probably can't play it on
youtube where we'll get pulled,
but we can play the Wii,
the audio,
right,
play the audio.
We'll put the video up on the
screen and play the audio for you.
And you could just fucking,
your head could turn beet red
smokes can come out of your ears.
Because the thing is about these videos,
and this is the issue that
I have with not just videos,
but also with blogs.
People,
you're writing things and you're not,
you're not being checked
as you're going along.
So it's,
it's just you broadcasting and idea.
It's not a conversation.
And because of that,
you can give off the illusion of
expertise without being checked.
Here it goes.
Dinosaurs never existed.
And by my God,
Eric to bay,
this is the,
the flat Earth Guy.
Yeah.
The guy that does 200 proofs,
the earth is flat.
Everybody has debunked.
Fucking,
oh no,
no,
no.
Shills shows or listen to this guy
of the royal society.
Don't you dare mention
anyone's name assholes,
natural history department
in 1842 or in other words,
the existence of dinosaurs was first
speculatively hypothesized by young
knighted museum head.
Coincidentally in the mid 19th century,
during the heyday of evolutionism before
a single dinosaur fossil had ever been
found wrong.
They sound pause,
pause every time.
Pause,
uh,
dinosaurs.
Uh,
we,
we discovered marine reptiles and the
first dinosaurs about a century before
that.
So that right there,
Eric,
you're fucking wrong.
Wups it's like,
don't bring your flat Earth
Bullshit into my profession.
Now I'm pissed.
But keep going.
Yeah,
keep,
keep us rolling
and stream.
Press worldwide.
Got To work hyping stories of
these supposedly long lost animals.
And then Lo and behold,
12 years later in 1854,
Ferdinand Vandeveer Hayden,
during his exploration of
the upper Missouri River,
found proof of Owen's theory.
A few unidentified teeth he mailed to
leading paleontologist Joseph Leidy,
who several years later declared them
to be from an ancient extinct track,
a don dinosaur,
which beyond ironic.
So
that's because we can do things like
look at modern analogs and see how teeth
are fucking made.
We know if it's a Predator or if its prey,
we know if it's an
herbivore or a carnivore,
we know how teeth are fucking built.
Even back then,
even when they're doing
naturalistic drawings like this,
it's like,
like the,
the,
the mcgalin on tooth on my arm.
It is a predator.
It's obviously a [inaudible]
Galla don or mega.
Dot.
How do you say it?
It depends on your,
you're in fast as can be
on a different syllable.
It's both.
It's not like nuclear new Cuellar no,
no cause cause it doesn't have to use,
um,
but it's spelled,
it's spelled the same but it's
like dimetrodon or dimetrodon.
Oh,
it's the same thing in the [inaudible] on,
Oh God,
you're God.
Keep doing this.
What is it?
20 minutes.
Firstly,
needless to say that it is impossible
to reconstruct an entire hypothetical
ancient animal based on a few teeth.
But even more importantly,
it is dubious that a myriad of tile,
bird and reptile mammal,
transitional forms necessary for the
blossoming theory of evolution would be
hypothesized and then conveniently
discovered by teams of evolutionist
archeologists purposely out
looking to find such fossils.
It is even more dubious that such fossils
have supposedly existed for millions
of years,
but we're never found by or known to
any civilization in the history of
humanity.
Kill evolution.
Okay.
Yeah.
The reason why we didn't know about
things beforehand because we weren't doing
shit like wholesale intellectual studies
of science when people were building
fucking pyramids and stuff like that.
That's why we have different ages in,
throughout anthropological records.
We have the brand age and Iron Age and
all that because we have to do things
like figure out the land around us.
And when we start finding
really old bones like,
hey,
this looks like a really big chicken bone.
What the fuck?
Or this looks like a huge
human with a single eye.
What the fuck?
We start looking at stuff like that saying
just wholesale fucking bullshit like
that.
Goddamn.
Ah,
but that's a,
that's what a youtube videos and
youtube conspiracy theory video is.
Oh,
I know.
One person getting to spill.
There's nonsense and w there unchecked.
Yeah.
This is why I wanted to play this for you.
And,
um,
uh,
response videos can be blocked
by the original person.
They can curate all comments.
They can only allow certain ones through.
They can moderate everything.
Same with a blog.
Same with all of that.
They control their own criticism.
There's a guy right now that
a lot of the Paleo community,
he's going after.
His name's David Peters.
He's a jackass,
um,
who's like doing stupid things like all
reptiles or mammals and all of these
claims should be in this
and just all this crap.
Um,
he wholesale copied an article from,
a colleague of mine posted it,
which is violation of copyright because
he's attempting to supersede that work
by importing his own ideas to it.
He will refuse any critical comments
to be posted on his wordpress site.
That's a little,
it's really common now.
Yeah.
It's really common with people.
The war of ideas in the comment section.
That's where it's being fought.
Yeah.
It's because it's an echo chamber.
It's like people don't look as why do
people think the world is flat or why do
people think dinosaurs don't exist there?
Google boolean search is dinosaurs
don't exist or creationism is true.
Evolution is false.
The earth is flat.
Chem trails exist.
They're creating their own echo chamber
and preaching to their own fucking
choir,
and then they have a message board
and then go on that message board.
Massive confirmation bias.
Nobody,
anybody that doesn't follow
that line gets booted out.
Let's play more of this because it gets,
it gets better.
Journalism's May sonic renaissance
in the mid 19th century,
David was and he wrote,
why are there no discoveries by native
Americans in all the years previous when
they roamed the American continents
because they weren't doing a fucking earth
dinosaurs in the native American religion
or tradition because they were all
dead that matter.
Why would there no discoveries prior
to the 19th century in any part of the
world there could have gone.
You didn't know what it was.
That's to the world book.
It's like the same thing
with mammoth cyclops.
Yeah.
We didn't know what the fuck it was.
We didn't know.
It was a massive,
a massive elephant species.
We thought it was a giant person.
Yeah.
When the first animals were
discovered in the liberate tarpits,
uh,
before 1913,
they thought it was livestock that
got trapped in there and died.
Then they realized,
holy fuck cows don't have nine
inch long incisors that are,
you know,
perfectly evolved to slash
open the throats of things.
And then you started questioning.
So the native Americans and all the
people they were finding possibly scatters
of bone and didn't know what it was.
Uh,
did the uh,
did the northern uh,
first people start
licking bones and rocks?
No,
we,
we discovered that,
you know,
the science as it figures out going,
hey,
this is porous material.
If I lik porous material,
it's going to stick to my tongue.
Holy Fuck,
that's a fossil.
This,
this,
this kind of just,
he,
the problem with you Eric,
is you are starting from
an improper position.
You are starting on a confirmation bias.
You are stating from the beginning that
dinosaurs don't exist and you were using
pair of Delia and apathy Enia the ability
for humans to find patterns in order
to fit your bullshit and then
only cherry pick what belongs.
That's,
that's what,
that's what he does
with fucking flat earth.
And the problem with this is
like I was saying earlier,
because now the stupid
minority has a voice.
All,
I dunno how many million people
subscribe to his fucking channel.
Every single flat earth dip shit
is going to go 61,000 people.
Okay,
look at that 300,000 views
and here's the thing.
Check out the comments.
The comments he calms
down are almost identical.
Look,
34 86 to 34 94 are you kidding me?
Son of a bitch.
Oh,
but I remember being forced to
have the same dinosaur toys.
Is Everyone Matt?
Yeah,
that's because it's called consumerism.
Flat Earth.
No dinosaur.
What's the point in making these?
Okay.
See,
good.
Good for you.
Go in there.
Extremely great research.
Love this very much.
Thank you Max Haskins.
Don't breed.
Don't ruin dinosaurs with facts.
Fuck you.
And there's more.
My favorite animal.
Here's another problem.
His voice is annoying as fuck.
Oh my God,
let's play more.
Oh thanks.
Good luck to you.
Before the 18 hundreds no one ever knew
that dinosaurs existed during the late
18 hundreds early 19 hundreds large
deposits of dinosaur remains were
discovered.
Why has man suddenly made
all these discoveries?
No tribes,
cultures or countries in the world ever
discovered a dinosaur bone before the
mid 18 hundreds and then they were
suddenly found all over the world in North
America,
South America,
Europe,
Asia,
Africa,
Argentina,
Belgium,
Mongolia,
Tanzania,
West Germany and many other places
apparently had larger deposits of dinosaur
fossils.
Never before seen.
Well because we find the
first one and then we're like,
Holy Shit,
there must be more of these out there.
And then the bone more started
between Ogden and marsh.
You had the man tell collection
with the first Iguanas,
Don that was found and they put it and
they made these really stupid statues and
put them in Crystal Palace in London.
And uh,
Mary Anning,
one of the first theme will be
first female pal paleontologist.
And one of the first people
actually find fossils.
She discovered the [inaudible] Mary
Anning was the girl from the rhyme.
She sells seashells on the seashore
cause that's what she did as a child.
And as she was looking for seashells,
she found a skeleton of an
atheist sore buried and a cliff.
Oh yeah.
As like a kid.
I think she was 12,
13 of Holy Shit.
I think paleontology,
Twitter is going to rip me
apart for not knowing the thing,
but come on,
I'm,
I'm hyped up now.
I'm drunk.
He's hyped up.
I'm not dude,
that's one beer.
All right.
I've got it.
Had before you got here.
None.
We got excited.
I've got nine more in there.
Um,
I'm going to need them.
Uh,
yeah,
it's just so Marianne and discovered
a [inaudible] and once you discover
something like that,
you want to go around the world and say,
Hey,
where else is this stuff?
Let's go somewhere that no one has been,
which means North America,
South America,
Tanzania believes all the things that
Captain Jack Ass just rattled off.
Captain Fuckface.
So Tom kept kept my face.
God fucking fuck.
What did shit given?
I don't know.
Just something.
Yeah,
I stole.
I stole shit given from a Trump thing,
but Gibbons shit given like a monkey,
like a gibbon monkey ape.
I think they're technically apes.
Gibbons are eight.
I think Gibbons are raped.
Hmm.
They have tails.
No Art.
All Apes.
Monkeys.
But not all monkeys or apes.
No.
Apes and monkeys are prime.
But a monkey is just,
it's not a technical term.
Right?
It's not a scientific term.
There was an article that was written
there was explaining that all apes or
monkeys,
but not all monkeys or apes.
See if you can find that.
Well,
we'll go to that afterwards probably
because like one of those beers.
Okay,
let's,
let's keep this rolling.
I don't want to,
I want to see how deep we can
go with this bake character.
I don't know what kind of explored
for thousands for this time.
No one ever found a
dinosaur fossil before.
According to the book,
the dinosaur project,
paleontological journalists,
Wayne Grady,
cause the period following this from
around 1870 to 1880 became a period in
North America where some of the most
underhanded shenanigans in the history of
science were conducted.
That's because of the two paleontologists
going at it against each other going,
I can find the cooler thing.
No,
I'm going to find more shit than you.
It was called the bone wars.
Ogden versus marsh.
You already talked about this,
right?
Yeah.
What was,
what was underhanded about it?
They would,
uh,
they would,
um,
sabotage each other's digs.
They would try and steal fossils.
They were assholes.
But because of the competition,
it's like a fight when
you have one dude that,
you know,
two dudes had been training all their
lives and trying to do the whole thing.
The more amped up one gets,
the more amped up the others gate.
It's going to be a fucking,
just throw down.
This is what happened on an
intellectual and fieldwork scale.
You had two guys trying to make a name
for themselves in a burgeoning brand new
field that just wanted to get in and
roll and they had direct competition with
each other.
So it's going to be,
you know,
fuck you.
I'm going to find these bones first.
And it,
it got nasty man.
Wow.
Yeah.
It's like,
think of it as Edison
versus Tesla's paleontology,
right?
Except Tesla wasn't very aggressive.
He sort of like let all that shit
true.
True,
very true.
Keep keep this going on as the great
dinosaur rash or the bone wars.
Edward Drinker Co of the academy off of
the Peabody Museum of natural history
began a lifelong rivalry and
passion for a dinosaur hunting.
I said on my bad,
but became bitter enemies during the
legendary feud involving double crossing
slander,
bribery,
theft,
spying and destruction
of bones by both parties.
Marsh is said to have discovered over 500
different ancient species including 80
dinosaurs while cope discovered 56 out
of the hundred and 36 dinosaur species
supposedly discovered by the two men.
However,
close with 32 are presently considered
valid as the rest of all proven to be
falsifications and fabrications.
Bullshit Bull Shit,
not a falsifications or fabrication.
Turns out a lot of those dinosaurs.
We're the same species that
were previously discovered,
so oh look,
this sauropod femur looks a lot like that.
Sauropod Femur,
but I found this slightly
in a different place,
so I'm going to name it a new species.
Nope.
Turns out those are both Brontosaurus
or a pat disorders or triceratops or
stegosaurs,
anything like that.
Um,
that,
that is just an outright
fucking lie that he just said.
When things are discovered,
it turns out that they're the same.
It becomes taxonomically
what's called a junior synonym.
So,
uh,
for example,
tyrannosaurus rex had another
name for a really long time.
It's totally mega,
mega,
no one,
regardless,
whatever the first name for it was,
was technically the first
discovered name for it.
But since tyrannosaurus rex
became the more popular,
the more documented,
the more thing that became
a junior synonym or what,
or in that one actually became
what we call no mum obscure him.
There were the obscure name no longer,
uh,
no longer talked about.
But that's what happened.
It wasn't an outright fabrication.
It was two dudes finding bones of
the same species or type of animal,
but not naming it the same thing.
So that's,
that's an absolute bullshit.
Eric Dubay outright lie
of them once claimed to find
a complete skeleton either.
So all their work
involved reconstructions,
in fact,
to this day,
no complete skeleton has ever been found.
And so all dinosaurs are reconstruction.
Well,
Shit.
Uh,
Su in the field museum is,
well,
not a hundred percent complete,
98% complete,
including formerly unknown
elements from any other train.
Assor.
Um,
I believe,
uh,
a commercial paleontology group just
found like a 99% or almost all 100%
complete dinosaur.
We have found entireties or
near entireties of animals.
So He's right by a very small
technicality of one or 2%.
Exactly.
But what he's implying
is completely misleading.
He's implying that they're finding a
shin bone and drawing and a dinosaur
around.
Exactly.
But no,
like we,
we'll find,
we can find 70% of a train.
This horse wrecks.
We know what they look like.
So yeah,
we will use three d printing
or casting of all that many.
And Yeah,
I'm happily admitting this
because everyone knows,
or at least everyone should know,
many dinosaurs in museums are
what we call conglomerates.
It will be,
uh,
see a triceratops.
The skull will be real.
Maybe the front half of the animals,
some ribs,
maybe some tail vertebrae or the
pelvis will be from one animal.
We will have to use casts of other
triceratops that we have throughout
paleontology in other museums.
Many of the fossils you see on display,
our casts now cast doesn't mean
bullshit created on the spot.
It means very technically,
this is a cast that is a replica of an
actual existing bone that was wrapped,
made a mold of,
and then filled with resin,
painted to the correct color.
It is the exact match
of a bone that exists.
It is not something we are just making up.
That is bullshit and I hate
that when they come in and go,
oh look,
that's link plastic.
Yeah,
it's plants and it gets all like,
well,
yeah,
you know why fossils are fucking fragile.
It takes us weeks to get a single bone
out and then it is covered in glue.
It is wrapped in tissue paper.
Sometimes tin foil,
a shit ton of plaster and
reinforcement is wrapped around it.
Then it has to be very carefully slid
down a mountain on a car hood in one time
or airlifted out in another and put in
the back of trucks and then take an all
the way to its museum and then cracked
open and then PR and then prepared
everything has to get,
uh,
get lift off it very carefully and we're
adding more glue as we're going because
if you sneeze wrong on some,
uh,
on some,
mineralized specimens,
it goes away.
It just goes boom.
So you have to work very carefully in
a booth with like an error Brater so
you're just,
you're shooting extremely fine particles
just to get the top millimeter of
material off.
This is hard detailed work on things that
are 65 plus million years old that if
we're not careful,
they fall apart.
We are not going to wrap something like
that in fucking steal and put it up on a
mount,
especially somewhere,
I dunno like Los Angeles where
things like earthquakes happen.
It's statements like that that he
makes are just fucking irritating.
Keep it,
keep it going.
The last thing he wrote,
discoveries and excavations.
The same not to be made by
disinterested people such as farmers,
ranchers,
hikers,
bullshit,
bullshit.
Building constructional issues they
face is a fucking lutely bullshit.
Fuck you Eric.
I'm a Paleo Monitor.
You asshole.
I am actually contracted to go out to
fucking building sites and make sure
fossils are protected
and dug up correctly.
In fact,
you know what Jack Ass,
I found a whale in downtown La.
Fuck you Eric.
Do Bay.
He found a whale.
I found a way only downtown away.
Oh,
you talked about this last podcast
you were talking about how to,
they had a shutdown construction.
Exactly.
You know why?
Cause building construction finds fucking
dinosaurs and Ma and whales and pre
stork animals.
You Jack Ass.
Ah,
fuck.
Fuck you farmers.
So,
uh,
sue was found on a guy's farm.
There have been numerous dinosaurs,
numerous prehistoric animals
found on a guy's farm.
By the way,
there's an entire private
area up in Bakersfield called
shark's tooth hill where
they find meg teeth.
Miguel on onto all the fucking time.
It's honors field in Bakersfield.
It's on private land farmers builders.
Recreational people.
Yeah.
Hey,
guess what?
A couple people hiking in Red Rock Canyon
up near Palmdale found a trackway from
an ancient camel rec.
We recreational people.
Yeah.
This happens all the fucking time.
The reason why it's happening more and
more lately it's because people know what
they're looking for now.
They understand.
Wow,
there could be shit out here.
Hey,
if we're digging a road,
if we're widening the
99 freeway in Fresno,
Holy Shit,
we hit a mammoth or holy shit,
we found a whale in downtown la like
with within blocks of the one 10 freeway
and good Samaritan Hospital.
I won't tell you where I can't,
but yeah,
I just wanted to secrecy.
Yeah.
It's just part of the part
of the contracts that's,
that's the deal.
Because if you find something,
if you find something there,
you can find more shit.
We found over 400 specimens
of shark teeth whale's,
uh,
or a rib cage of a whale,
snails,
fossil coral,
all of this because downtown La was
underwater 7 million years ago and yeah,
that's,
Oh my God,
that's fucking bullshit.
Ah,
keep going.
Yeah.
Blind trench digger and mining industry
personnel found all the time by people
with a vested interest such
as paleontologists scientists,
university professors,
and museum organization personnel
who meaning trained motherfuckers,
dinosaur bones,
or who have studied dinosaurs previously.
Fines are often made during
special dinosaur bone
hunting trips and expeditions
by these people to far away regions
already inhabited and explored.
This seems highly implausible.
More believable is the case of the
discovery of the first original Dead Sea
Scrolls in 1947 which were unintentionally
discovered by a child and which were
all published by 1955
Oh,
okay.
So it's perfectly fine to accidentally
find ancient scrolls or silver dinero AI
from the Roman period or a never
before known pyramid and South America.
Oh no,
that's cool.
You know why?
Because humans fucking made those.
But it's completely out
of the norm for some kid,
some nine year old kid to be walking
around Montana and find a mummified
Hadrosaur because I don't know
why I made that distinction.
That's it were weird comparison.
There's,
yeah,
it's more plausible the find the Dead Sea
Scrolls in Qumran than it is to find a
megalodon tooth bullshit.
Bakersfield's yeah,
that doesn't make any sense.
No,
no.
It doesn't make any sense.
He's,
he's anthropomorphise sizing
this and he's using a very,
an absolutely invalid invalid argument
and a logical fallacies trying.
He's trying to,
its absolute false equivocation.
He's trying to go,
oh,
well,
you know,
you can't find this
stuff because it's super,
super old,
but you can find this stuff because it's
younger and it's humans and you know,
people live there.
So we'd expect stuff there.
Well guess what,
asshole?
There's 65 million years of difference
between humans deciding to write shit
down and go,
hey,
uh,
there's a day and a night.
That means something's
ruling the day in the night.
God's religion and industry and all that,
and dinosaurs eating
shit 65 million years.
You,
we were tree shrews and moles.
We didn't,
we weren't building shit.
We weren't writing stuff down.
Such a false fucking argument.
God,
this guy said,
check.
So some cases of a discovery of dinosaur
bones by a disinterested person.
It was suggested to them by some
professional in the field [inaudible] in a
certain area.
It wasn't also very interesting to
note our special areas set aside and
designated as dinosaur parks
because we found a judging short.
Hector's are required to first
obtain a dinosaur hunting license,
whatever destination these establishment
finance national's hard paleontologists
set,
it seemed,
they found incredible numbers
of fossils and tiny areas.
In one of the largest dinosaur excavation
sites called the Ruth Mason Corey,
over 2000 fossils were
allegedly discovered.
Stop saying,
fuck legend skeleton assembled from these
bones are currently on display in over
60 museums worldwide because dino head
of paleontology at Laplata museum is
amazingly responsible for 6,000 fossil
species supposedly discovered throughout
his career all in Argentina or oh really?
Really?
Hey,
guess what Eric?
I ran a lab that we had three and a half
million specimens from the ice age that
goes back 90,000 years.
So the libray a tarpits,
the largest ice age mammal collection on
the fucking planet and this stuff isn't
mineralized.
It's actually subsumed
with asphalt keeping the,
uh,
all of the calcium and everything intact.
These are actual bones.
When we find a saber tooth cat tooth,
it's the physical tooth of the animal.
Ooh.
Which is kind of freaky
to think about but,
but,
but seeing that it's like,
yeah,
we find a lot of shit in places.
The river of death and Alberta d
when they're digging the pipeline,
um,
I dunno.
Mammoth hot springs.
There are things called death traps and
Predator traps in sinkholes and natural
trap caves and I don't know,
entire sand dunes falling on things
while they're fighting the dueling
dinosaurs.
It's a air tops versus a velociraptor
that was found in Mongolia because of
fucking sand.
Dune fell on them while they were tussling
around cause the v Raptor wanted to
eat the thing it that,
that,
that's a rad specimen by the way.
You know what's interesting about this
guy is that he knows so much is that his,
his,
his knowledge of the history
of paleontology and of
researching dinosaur bones,
he knows so much I call bullshit on that.
What I'm thinking is that he's reading
from a script that he cobbled together on
fucking Wikipedia.
I challenge him to go toe to toe
with somebody in the business.
I don't know,
like me and go,
okay,
start throwing date.
Start throwing specimens.
I will fucking own you be,
you know what I'm saying?
I mean he's,
he's obviously,
he knows all these people.
He knows about the bone
war as he knows well,
who's in charge of all these different
simple Google search of largest dinosaur
thing found.
Okay,
I'm going to write these three
things down on this Manila in Manila.
Fucking,
I understand that.
I'm not saying that it's,
it's impressive and that
it's conclusive evidence.
I'm saying it's,
it's impressive that this guy has done
this much research but yet still has this
ridiculous idea and he's used to this.
Yeah.
He's using all this data that's actually
factual about how many different people
found how many different things and
he's decided that this is proof and all
information allegedly in front of it.
Yeah.
It's like,
no,
sorry.
Over 6,000 specimens were found there.
Fucking go with it.
Hunter.
Earl Douglas sent 350 tons of excavated
dinosaur bones to the Carnegie Museum of
Natural History.
Throughout his career,
all coming from the Dinosaur
National Monument in Utah.
Why do you think it's called the
dinosaur national monument now,
Dr. Lewis Chackbay and Dr Lowell,
a key off bay,
actually thousands of dinosaur eggs at a
site of only a few hundred square yard.
It was called the
tiniest giant exhibition.
How such fines have huge quantities of
fossils in one area by just a few highly
invested individuals.
It goes against the laws of natural
probability to the likelihood of forgeries
or concentrated planting efforts wrong.
If you find a fossil planting efforts,
the plant,
what were the things that they planted?
They,
there's dinosaur bones that they planted,
that's the dinosaur bones
made out of like residency.
So that is actually an
argument with these jackasses.
It's like,
okay,
so big Paleo.
The big paleontologist,
people like me being Paleo,
Paleo,
big Pharma,
and big they,
and you know all that podcast,
Jamie.
We're big podcasts where an industry,
so they say they not in the black man,
you know,
black helicopter day,
but they as in the detractors
state that paleontologists like me,
we'll create a fossil,
whether it's like a cast or we'll just
make one up and on these expeditions we
go out and we actually bury it and
uncover it and make the news and all that.
Well,
if that was true,
Eric,
why is it that when we
find something say in,
I dunno,
okay.
It's not usually written about until
say 2012 and that's just a symbol,
a single note in the Journal
of Vertebrate Paleontology,
which I guarantee you've never read or
it's done as a poster at the Society of
Vertebrate Paleontology,
which I will absolutely
guarantee you've never been to.
Yeah.
And then the fossils still
in prep at that point,
we haven't done all the research on it.
It's still undiscovered fossil found.
If we are going out and investing all of
this money in order to make these fakes
and bury them and pay all of these people
to shut them up and huge excavations
like that,
we would kind of want to recoup that
money as fast as possible and immediately
dump it to the news and get paid
for spokesman ships and all of that,
but we don't.
We suffer natural history.
Museums are some of the lowest donated
two institutions on the planet.
Art Museums are generally number one.
There are people that get laid
off all the time from museums,
museums close.
If we were making all this
money and making all this fame,
why are there
paleontologists out of a job?
Why do I know a dozen monitors
that don't have work right now?
Why are their museums that have problem
actually getting a budget to get an
excavation going that they
have to use private donors,
that they have to use
their board of directors,
that they have to go from a
county museum to a foundation,
nonprofit non profit.
This is such a line of
fucking bullshit that,
I mean that that pisses me off because
his simple statements are looping in
thousands and tens of thousands of
employees and museums and all of that
worldwide.
This would be one of the largest
conspiracies ever other than,
I dunno.
Moon hoax is a NASA earth flat
earth and shit other he does.
Yeah.
That is the other one.
Keep gone.
Ah,
let's get them one on one.
Dinosaur bones sell for a
lot of money at auctions.
It is a profitable business.
There is pressure for
academics to publish papers.
Museums are in the business of
producing displays that are popular and
appealing.
What the nonprofit uselessness media need
to produce material to sell to stay in
business.
The mainstream media loves to hype alleged
dinosaur fines much just to be gained
by converting a bland non
dinosaur discovery of a bone
of modern origin into an
impressive dinosaur.
Find and letting artists interpretations
and imaginations take the spotlight.
Okay.
Rather than the basic boring real find.
Um,
if,
if that's true,
then why do dinosaurs become passe?
Why does somebody like who has been on,
I don't know,
13,
14 different television shows
talking about paleontology,
geology and all that.
I have pitched dinosaur,
like live dig stuff to
BBC and all of that.
I'm consulting on a
couple projects right now,
unfortunately,
can't name them,
but uh,
dinosaurs become passe very,
very quickly because people are like,
oh,
cool.
New dinosaurs found.
Yeah.
Big Deal.
Or Oh well brontosauruses back.
Yeah,
whatever.
But the mainstream media as he said,
is just like,
they love a dinosaur story,
but that's bullshit.
That's absolute bullshit.
When was the women's the
last like dinosaur document?
Yeah,
there was um,
uh,
what was it called?
Autopsy of a t rex with,
uh,
my friend Tori and uh,
that,
that okay.
That was a speculative science show.
It was like,
what happens if we found a t rex
and cut it open and do an autopsy?
That was a hit and then paleontology
TV died again two years ago.
I had a,
to our national geographic documentary
about digging up wooly mammoths in that
it aired a night.
There was a little bit
of press fucking done.
The production company that did the,
the,
the thing with nat geo
is out of business now,
just done.
It's like,
really?
We're,
we're pressured and to get this money
then why aren't we making fucking more?
Why Eric,
am I a bartender in addition
to a paleontologist in
addition to somebody that's
on TV,
if I making all this big Pharma or sorry,
big Paleo fucking money.
If I'm such a shill.
Okay.
Yeah.
Is that why I'm a month behind
on my car payment right now?
Is that why I'm trying
to scrape together rent?
Fuck.
You can aggressive.
Oh,
I'm very aggressive.
Fuck these guys.
Fame and attention.
There's the bandwagon effect and
crowd behavior and then their entity.
Wait,
but wait,
wait,
wait.
The bandwagon effect and the crowd
behavior like flat earth bullshit.
Okay.
We're only seven minutes and 53
seconds into a 29 minute video.
Fuck all.
We don't have to keep going.
I don't want you to get too mad.
I think you kind of made your point.
You can pull the plug in anytime you want,
but now it's like one of
those Twitter arguments.
Man.
Now I'm getting invested,
fucking troll me all the time
because we follow each other,
we DM each other and all
of a sudden in my thing,
it's like I have you on note
cause we're both verified,
it pops up and it's just like Joe
Rogan is tweeting about flat earth.
I'm like fuck.
And then just go for it.
It's like you're,
I mean like,
you know the podcast and like flight
commentary and UFC stuff and like with
your,
with like triggered
coming out and all that.
That's one thing when
you rile up the cranks,
man,
you're just like,
you're at the same level.
Just actually you have,
how many followers do you have?
Like 2 million,
right?
Does it like on Twitter?
Uh,
Tdt a take a Darwin.
I like 10,
maybe 15,000.
I get the same level of
riled from both of you.
Fuck man.
So we need to fly him out
and have him on the show.
This guy,
this?
No,
no,
Eric.
No,
no,
no.
Take that Darwin.
Yeah,
no,
he,
he'd be a fun,
he would be Rad.
Yeah,
you would be fun.
Fuck Eric Dubay.
If he's ever on the show,
I want to be outside waiting
with a fucking baseball bat.
Oh,
how do you want to be violent with him?
Almost almost that you
want to talk to him.
Would you have to meet?
I think you could gain a lot from sitting
down with a guy like this and just
sort of picking them apart because you
would realize what he was wrong about and
instead of him being able to just spout
off on a youtube video who'd would be
checked at every step of the way
whenever he said something incorrect.
Yes,
but the problem is the only
reason why I would do that,
he will never change his mind.
Well,
he's probably crazy.
Duh.
He's absolutely crazy.
But think about it right now.
You have 4 million subscribers
that now know this video exists,
that no Eric debased name,
that know that paleontologist
w can get riled up by this guy.
They're now going to go look,
if any one of your listeners is
on the fence about dinosaurs,
why would you be?
But you could have some,
those are the people that I
would have to try and convince.
I will never convince him.
I will mock the living shit out of him
until he wants to put himself into a
chipper shredder.
But I will never convince him.
It's the,
and that's,
that's the thing.
So all you Sai Khan people out there,
we don't do it to try and convince the
big mouth pieces for these movements were
trying to go for the people that aren't
quite sure if we embarrass the living
fuck out of these people,
those people would go,
wow,
those guys are idiots.
Why did I even consider
that the world is flat,
or the dinosaurs didn't exist,
or creationism exists,
or chem trails or Nibiru fucking
rogue planets and shit like that.
Okay.